hi i'm christine goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
gop lawmakers are calling for answers
from facebook and twitter
over both platforms limiting the reach
of a new york post article
about hunter biden south dakota senator
jon thune discusses the criticism
surrounding these companies content
moderation decisions
and the issue of health care and with 18
days until election day
most national polls continue to show
former vice president joe biden
leading president trump and state polls
have him ahead of key battleground
states
like arizona and florida fox news sunday
host chris wallace shares his insight
on the chances of the president
achieving a comeback and how the
coronavirus pandemic
could impact the race plus commentary by
jimmy fayla
host of fox across america the fox news
rundown is a daily news podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm abby hornacek this is tucker carlson
and i'm jessica tarlov this is the fox
news rundown
friday october 16th 2020
i'm lisa brady as the presidential
campaigns
barrel toward the finish line a fierce
fight also continues
for control of the u.s senate it's
critically important
as well in all of these states where we
have competitive senate races that
people turn out
and uh and make their voices heard and
let you know the
the republicans continue to control the
united states senate i'm chris foster
fox news sunday host chris wallace says
about what's left of the presidential
race i don't know who's going to win the
election
uh but i would say at this point if you
said to me who would you rather be
would you rather be the trump campaign
manager or the biden campaign manager
at this moment i'd rather be the biden
campaign manager
and i'm jimmy fella i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
since winning his personal bout with
coronavirus president trump's been back
on the campaign trail
with a vengeance
chance of four more years in greenville
north carolina thursday
his fourth rally in four days as he
continues to dismiss
polls showing joe biden in the lead
while on capitol hill the motion is not
agreed to
the senate judiciary committee along
party lines rejecting a democrat
proposal to delay a vote on supreme
court nominee amy coney barrett
the committee is now scheduled to vote
next thursday on sending her nomination
to the senate floor
a customary one-week layover after
confirmation hearings
that leaves plenty of time to meet the
president's goal of having barrett on
the court
before election day i think both sides
are going to be
very motivated in this election and i
think the supreme court
only probably further intensifies that
motivation
south dakota senator john thune is not
up for re-election this year
he's the number two republican in the
senate the majority whip
the supreme court nomination typically
brings out
high intensity on both sides the
question is what are those voters in the
middle think about all this
and how are they going to be persuaded
having watched
the process now for the past several
days and my view is it's going to help
uh with republicans i think that you
know the the judge did a terrific job i
think she acquitted herself extremely
well
proved how qualified she is and if
anybody was watching those hearings they
had to walk away from it
with that conclusion uh that being said
um
you know we've got a ways to go to get
her through the you know final vote in
the senate but
it seems to me at least anyway that when
you're talking about a supreme court
nomination
as qualified as amy coney barrett that
certainly is helpful to republicans
politically
and i suspect that come election day if
people are thinking about
the supreme court if they're thinking
about the judicial process and what they
want to see
on the court that that's going to
incline them to to
favor republicans when it comes to how
they vote in the election
what about the issue of health care
though it was a big issue in the 2018
midterm elections for democrats it
dominated much of judge barrett's
hearings
you know what could happen if the
supreme court essentially throws out
obamacare is that issue an election
vulnerability
for republicans you know i think that
the democrats believe that it is
obviously because they're running an
awful lot of ads they're spending
enormous amounts of money millions and
millions tens of millions of dollars
attacking republicans
on that issue but the fact of the matter
is
our candidates at least our senate
candidates around the country have a
really good response i mean our members
are all
in favor of preserving protections for
pre-existing conditions
and i think the the supreme court
nomination was an opportunity for
democrats to attack the nominee
on the issue of what you might do
hypothetically
if the affordable care act when if you
know she's on the court when it's
considered
but i thought she answered it really
well and i think she's a very
she's a judge who is going to apply the
law and the constitution an
impartial way and not try and legislate
pre-ordained outcomes or results and
what democrats typically want in a judge
is somebody who
will almost act as an auxiliary
legislator
who will help them get the results and
outcomes that they have been able to get
through the political branches of our
government
and so i think this is a this experience
that we've had
watching her respond to these questions
although the democrats tried as hard as
they could to badger her
on a potential hypothetical i thought
she answered it really well
and i think it's very clear that
whatever happens with the supreme court
on obamacare
republicans are committed to making sure
that we have protections for
pre-existing conditions
and alternatives in place that would be
a much better
solution for the american people than
the obamacare
bill which is frankly has driven up
premiums and out-of-pocket costs
deductibles
and everything else for most americans
just one more question
about the health care issue though
because democrats are always saying well
republicans haven't
yet put forth a comprehensive
alternative to obamacare do you think
that's
necessary is that a question that sort
of hangs over this especially for
republicans who are out there trying to
hold on to the senate this year
yeah you know i think that the bigger
issue really when it comes to health
care
is what a lot of the democrats including
those uh you know
a lot of them in the running for
elective office in the congressional
level but certainly it's been a subject
of conversation
uh during the democrat nomination
process for president
is uh you know going to a single-payer
national health care system which would
take away the coverage
that uh the hundreds of you know
millions tens of millions and actually
about 160 million americans currently
get
through their employer and many of them
are very happy with that insurance and
so i think the issue of
health care and health coverage
insurance coverage uh cuts
both ways democrats obviously try and
point to
the shortcomings in a republican
position
on this particular aspect of it or that
but i think for most americans it's
really about what does it cost
what is my coverage uh do i have access
to quality care
and is it an affordable price you know
the health care issue is one that
democrats see as something that has
political advantage for them
but when it comes to actually providing
solutions for the american people i
think the republican approach
a free market approach that allows them
to keep the coverage that they like
provides those for you know medicare
medicaid
uh others who need it need coverage
provides protections for those as well
but in the end gives them options that
create a competitive environment where
they're getting lower prices and better
care
the president keeps hammering joe biden
over allegations of potentially
inappropriate behavior
connected to a son's business dealings
while he was vice president
is that something you think the senate
should spend time holding hearings on
i would say it's probably uh something
that
the relevant committee chairman if they
choose to
certainly could look at i mean i think
there is enough there there's enough
smoke there
certainly there could be some fire but i
think
in terms of you know the timing and the
schedule what we're looking at between
now and the election
at least in the senate we have the the
barrett nomination we'll try and move
that across the floor
we do have some hearings scheduled um
for
next week in the senate where we will
actually have or should say the
following week in the senate we will
actually have
uh the the heads of the big three tech
companies google
and facebook and twitter uh in front of
congress
and i think that'll be an interesting
hearing as well but to the degree that
time allows for it and that the relevant
committee chairs think there's uh
information there that needs to be made
available to the american people needs
to be delved into a little bit more
deeply
i certainly wouldn't be surprised if
that were to happen some of your
colleagues are now accusing
some of the social media companies of
election interference
because of their moves to restrict
uh the latest reporting about possible
hunter biden emails
for instance and there's talk of
subpoenas um
in in that regard that could be another
round of hearings with with some of
these social media
executives is that you know
a road that you'd maybe rather go down
or do you think that's
that's going too far to call it election
interference
well i think that the question is a fair
one and and needs to be posed of these
tech companies
and frankly should they be the final
arbiters of what the truth is
and they have enormous um you know
ability and frankly monopoly power when
it comes to
suppressing or amplifying what we see on
social media platforms
so we did have to subpoena we we
subpoenaed we voted to subpoena and the
commerce committee
uh google twitter and facebook and they
are coming in now voluntarily
the threat of a subpoena evidently was
enough to get them to come
so they're going to come in front of the
commerce committee the judiciary
committee as you point out also now
is subpoenaing those same companies but
i think this is an issue that needs to
be looked at
and i and frankly um you know if you're
going to have the protections that they
have
under the law when it comes to liability
you can't be out there
arguing that you're a neutral platform
and at the same time be a publisher in
other words
uh moderating the content that goes on
to your platform
and that's the the the question that's
really uh
we're trying to answer here is how do we
make sure
that these tech companies are operating
in a way that is transparent where
they're held accountable to the american
people
and where their content moderation
policies are not censoring
conservative or any other type of
content for that matter
joe biden has denied any wrongdoing as
vice president
as for the social media restrictions on
the latest allegations
twitter ceo jack dorsey says his company
should do a better job of explaining why
when it decides to block something one
thing that keeps hitting a roadblock in
washington
another stimulus bill president trump
telling fox business thursday
he's prepared to go even bigger i think
there's a chance
i do because i think there's a lot of
pressure on pelosi house speaker nancy
pelosi has continued talks with treasury
chief steve mnuchin
but the gap remains between the latest
plan from house democrats
over two trillion dollars and a white
house proposal of 1.8 trillion which
senate majority leader mitch mcconnell
says
is too high for senate republicans he's
preparing to put a 500 billion dollar
package to a vote
we voted on a bill in the united states
senate a couple of weeks ago that we had
52 republican senators out of 53 vote
for
it was a very balanced bill it was very
targeted it was fiscally responsible
i had a price tag of about 650 billion
dollars
and of course what the democrats in the
house are talking about is several
trillion dollars on top of the three
and a half or so trillion that we've
already spent
all of which by the way was borrowed
money and i think any decision that we
make going forward
uh we need to be very aware of the
impact we're going to have on our
children's
future if we continue to pile up more
and more debt
and the resources that we put on this
problem
and there are some and there are issues
out there that need to be addressed and
we're going to have to do more we know
that
but we can't just yield to every demand
the democrats make right now
for now it looks like it we're a little
bit at uh
at odds but i think after we get the
election behind us hopefully and the
dust settles and the smoke clears we can
come together and do some things that
are meaningful but that are targeted
are fiscally responsible and aren't just
literally piling trillions and trillions
of more debt on the backs of our
children and grandchildren
one last thing senator here we are less
than three weeks to election day now
millions already voting how concerned
are you about republicans possibly
losing control of the senate this year
well you know we've got a lot of
competitive races we know that they're
there are right now they're just as
tight as can be out there
and unbelievable amounts of money being
spent i mean i can't even tell you
how stunning it is the the amount of
money and our candidates in
all of these competitive races are going
to be outspent by their democratic
opponents because there is so much
uh democrat money flowing into these
states this year
but even with that uh we've got some
really good strong
candidates who are running good
campaigns um are
you know good fits for their state and
it's a bad political environment this
year
overall at least right now but i think
even
even with some of these headwinds that
we have the type the quality of
candidates
uh with the right resources although
they're going to be outspent
and the right message that i think can
come across the finish line
and save the majority for us in the
senate and the reason that should be
that's important the american people is
irrespective of what happens at the you
know with the presidential race
the united states senate uh literally is
the firewall
against a really radical democrat agenda
so i hope his people
around the country when they go to vote
this year
you know we want them obviously we want
to win the presidential race but it's
critically important
as well in all of these states where we
have competitive senate races that
people turn out
and uh and make their voices heard and
let
you know the uh the republicans continue
to control the united states senate
senate majority whip john foon thank you
very much for your time sir
thanks lisa nice to be with you
this is jimmy fella with your fox news
commentary coming up
we were supposed to have been talking
about president trump and joe biden's
second debate last night that was called
off when the president
refused to do it remotely a change
organizers wanted because of his
coronavirus infection
he says that's over with but instead of
a debate we get separate televised town
halls with president trump hosted by nbc
news in miami
my question to you is how are you going
to get the united states back on track
both in terms of the economy and the
pandemic
so it's happening we're just at a record
11.4 million jobs
we are going to have a phenomenal third
quarter which will be announced
on november 1st just prior to the big
november third day where i think you'll
see a red wave
but we're going to have a tremendous
announcement i believe i mean we're
going to find out but gdp is going
through the roof
jobs real estate houses
so many things are happening and joe
biden in a town hall moderated by abc
news
george stephanopoulos in philadelphia
you stated that anyone making
less than 400 thousand dollars will not
see one single penny of their taxes
raised
that's right also state that you are
going to eliminate the trump tax cuts
the trump tax cuts reduces taxes for the
majority of workers
i would argue not enough what is your
plan for either extending the tax cuts
for the middle class or creating a new
plan that further reduces those taxes
i carry this card with me when i said
the tax the
trump tax cuts about 1.3 trillion
of the two trillion dollars in his tax
cuts went to the top one tenth of one
percent
that's what i'm talking about
eliminating not all the tax cuts
that are out there his vice presidential
nominee kamala harris canceled her
campaign travel through at least sunday
because of coronavirus cases
and people on her team the democrats
maintained their lead in presidential
polls nationwide and in many states won
by president trump in 2016
also raising a record amount of cash
last month 383 million dollars
joe biden has a lead now and i do think
he has a lot of advantages chris wallace
is the host of fox news sunday it
seems that the trump campaign has a
money crunch i mean they're
dark and local tv and iowa and ohio and
they're pulling ads i think they pulled
last sunday it was a stat we had we
didn't get to on the show that they had
pulled 20
million dollars worth of ads out of uh
the upper midwest michigan wisconsin
minnesota
ohio iowa uh and and moved 20 million
into the sun belt uh that's not good
because it really
that's playing defense that's protecting
places that you won four years ago
rather than playing offense and trying
to win things so
look i don't know who's going to win the
election uh but i would say at this
point if you said to me who do you
who would you rather be would you rather
be the trump campaign manager or the
biden campaign manager
at this moment i'd rather be the biden
campaign well the biden campaign manager
says they think the election is going to
be a lot closer than those polls that
could just be also something you say to
stave off
complacency which may have hurt hillary
a little bit last time
and and uh push turnout absolutely i
mean
it may be true and you certainly after
what happened four years ago don't want
to be
uh spiking the football uh before you
get in the end zone but
you know i think that a lot of that is
uh we've got to still get out we got to
get our
votes out early voting uh mail-in voting
and you know and election day voting
this time four years ago
the donald trump access hollywood tape
had just come out like a week before
um and that looked to be hurting him and
then james comey
fbi director on october 29th announced
the resumption of the hillary clinton
email investigation
and that may have swung things a bit
voters just seem to be less elastic this
time around i don't know what it could
possibly be
um no except turnout you know it may be
the one thing that i i think and this
was certainly true
not an outside event but a hidden vote a
vote that doesn't show up in the polls
you know we know we know that there is a
tremendous line of people i have to say
it's
quite inspiring to see these people
waiting at
seven hours to vote uh i don't think
there's anything i would wait seven
hours for
uh you know but waiting uh out in the in
the cold or the heat or whatever
for seven hours to vote in in in
virginia and georgia and a bunch of
other states um you know we don't but we
don't know are they voting for trump or
are they voting for
biden and um i agree with you that that
what's so fascinating is that there have
been so many huge events
in this campaign whether it's covid
whether it's the economic collapse and
now
rebirth whether it was uh a very unusual
first debate the president getting
coveted but you know the
the polls have stayed remarkably stable
and
biden has maintained you know somewhere
from a
a seven to 11 point lead really since
march so so you do you know that that's
one thing that wouldn't
seem to indicate that that's where
things are going but
um you know you just don't know if
there's a hidden
trump vote and it'll come out and you
know i got egg on my face last time i'm
mixing my uh you know my humble my
metaphors here i'm not getting egg in my
face this time i am an absolute agnostic
as to who's going to win the election my
only hope
my only hope chris is that there's a
winner a clear winner on election night
and you know we can put this behind us
the country will have decided
we've got a new president if you'd like
him right if you don't like him
deal with it get over it and let's move
on with our lives
this new york post hunter biden story
about files from a computer what do you
make of the story
a and b what do you make about it's
being blocked for um
for sharing on facebook and twitter i
think the story is very sketchy not
saying it's not true
but it seems to me it needs a lot of
investigation
uh the the the guy who you know who ran
the computer store is supposedly legally
blind he's not sure who
even came in with the computers he says
that
uh although the story keeps changing
that he gave it to the fbi last december
but you know they're not confirming that
now he's saying
that he gave it to rudy giuliani's
lawyer rudy giuliani is not the most
independent source on all this stuff so
i think it's absolutely worth
investigating
um and but i'm not sure i'd even go with
it at this point
but um as far as as facebook and twitter
banning it i got a real problem with
that i
you know i think you're either in or
you're out and when i say that either
it's the wild west
and you post everything and i can
understand the concern about that after
what happened
in 2016 with russian disinformation
or you put everything out there and
and if you have a problem with some of
it like
for instance this story which i do think
is sketchy then then put a
uh a word on there to to your users
and say you know we can't confirm the
story or you know there's some
some questions with this story but to
just ban it
and to say nobody is allowed to discuss
this story or post this story
which you know is is out there you can't
you can't put the genie back in the
bottle it was the front page of the new
york post
uh really strikes me as as smacking a
big
brother yeah and it's one of those you
know the streisand effect that
that principle that if you barbara's
there's a negative story about barbara
streisand years ago she brought
publicity to it otherwise nobody would
have known about it
there's a little bit of that here
there's a little bit of that here where
if
the story hadn't been banned fewer
people would know about it
no that's right which to the degree that
people think that they're
in in the tank to buy them and they do
certainly seem to
to tilt liberal uh it has backfired
because i agree
it has created not just the story about
the story but the story about how big
media giants are handling it
right now it does not look like we're
going to get coronavirus
financial relief happening before the
election uh treasury secretary
uh treasury secretary steve mnuchin says
he doesn't see it happening
are you surprised something just
bipartisan didn't get worked out or that
the president didn't push it harder just
to help reelection if nothing else
yeah i i am and i the problem is
that you know i think that the nancy
pelosi and they
they passed a three trillion dollar bill
in may and i think she never
felt uh a lot of pressure to come up
with a deal or to make a deal because of
the fact that the republicans were such
in such disarray the president refused
to negotiate i think he could have made
it a lot harder
for democrats to stonewall if he had uh
called everybody into the white house
you know let's have a summit meeting and
pelosi and schumer and mcconnell and uh
and minutes and then all of those people
uh he never did that and and in fact it
was just tremendous disagree on the
republican side i mean
uh right now you've got uh the president
saying let's go
big let's go even bigger than the two
trillion dollars nancy pelosi is talking
about
while at the same time you have the
republicans senators
uh saying you know we want it to be
under a trillion dollars we want it to
be
four or five hundred billion and and
calling out mitch mcconnell so
i think it's been easy for nancy pelosi
to stonewall
and and forget the question of covert
relief as you know we're going to pass a
bill
i think it ultimately ends up hurting
the the president because he either
you know he gets he's boosted or hurt by
the state of the economy into the degree
that you're not getting
and now it would be too late anyway but
for the election but
the fact that you're not getting two
trillion dollars of stimulus of one and
a half trillion dollars of stimulus in
the economy a month ago
probably hurts the economy and makes
people feel less
uh content with with where things are
right now which probably
you know never helps the incumbent new
corona virus restrictions are in effect
in france and england now no indoor
gatherings
of people you don't live with in london
do you think the barn door is just
ripped off the hinges here though like
no matter how bad
this late fall and winter might be uh
it's just gonna be more openings no
matter what
well no i mean i i do think it's going
to take a lot for you to see
restrictions but we are seeing
restrictions you're seeing
them in new york in new york state
you're seeing some in in wisconsin
you know i i think are we going to see a
national shutdown i think that's
really hard to see that happening
because you know too many people just
won't accept it
uh it won't abide by it but but could
you see
more isolated restrictions in a bunch of
places you know and i think it all
depends
on the state of the uh of the virus and
you know look i hope look i'd like the
darn thing to go away tomorrow but i i
as i've said all along in our
conversations chris you gotta follow the
the
the science and if the science says
there's been a huge new up
outbreak and you know god forbid like a
new strain of the virus or whatever
you got to do what needs to be done to
keep people safe
so uh i hope it doesn't come to that and
i think it would be harder
for it to come to that now than it was
in march after what happened in march
but
i'm never going to say never uh one more
chris anything strike you from the
amy coney barrett hearings anything she
anything from her testimony anything
from the questioning i mean safe to say
was certainly a lot quieter than
brett kavanaugh's a couple years ago
well i think
she did you know did a good job she's
going to be confirmed
uh it seemed to me that the democrats
kind of knew that going in and they
seemed less interested in trying to
disqualify her which i don't think they
could have done anyway
and more interested in in scoring
political points for the election
and you know the best issue for
democrats in 2018 in the midterms
was healthcare and they really focused
on healthcare we've had more talks on
healthcare and pre-existing conditions
and 26 year olds on their parents
policies
in the last this week than we've had in
the last maybe the whole campaign
and you know i think that could be
effective in raising that as an issue
again
for people but in terms of amy coney
barrett's
confirmation to the court unless
something completely unforeseen
happens uh she'll be justice barrett
before election death
chris wallace is the host of fox news
sunday a frequent guest here on the fox
news rundown chris thanks a lot
you bet thank you correct
[Music]
it's the latest from fox news podcasts
the campaign with bret bear with updates
from reporters on the trail and
in studio experts brett keeps you
informed on the 2020 race go to
foxnewspodcast.com and download the
campaign with brett bear
now and now some good news with tanya j
powers hundreds of florida students are
not only learning about space
but they'll soon have their own souvenir
from it postcards made by students at
river city science academy in
jacksonville will be included in an
upcoming rocket launch
the assignment was to answer the
question why do you think the earth
needs space
jace is a fifth grader who told
jacksonville's action news jax tv
the answer that inspired his drawing i
drew a spacesuit
that can go to different planets morgan
galena is a teacher at river city
science academy
and worked on the project with the kids
the very open-ended like
what could we eventually do in space
what can we use space for
the postcards will be launched into
outer space aboard the new shepard
part of blue origin which is jeff bezos
rocket company
the new shepherd is named for mercury
astronaut alan shepard and it makes
11-minute trips to space from its launch
pad in texas
it's all part of the earth needs space
project for the club for the future
which is blue origin's non-profit
organization
galena says it's a project with an eye
toward the future
this can be a career that they can
eventually go into something with space
each postcard will be given back to the
students with a flown from space
stamp excited to get it back it's going
to be really cool
if you'd like to know more about how to
send postcards into space
go to clubforfuture.org tanya j
powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
jimmy fala
what's on your mind president trump has
been calling joe biden the pro-lockdown
candidate for this entire food fight of
a campaign
but you don't need the president's words
to believe it just look at the former
vp's campaign schedule
the biden team has called a lid on
public appearances four times in the
past week before 10 o'clock in the
morning
folks we're less than three weeks from a
presidential election and biden isn't
exactly fighting to the death
if anything he's fighting till the nap
most people listening to this right now
have campaigned harder to be president
of their fantasy football league
than joe has to be president of the
united states which begs the question
how can the rest of us ever expect to
get out of our houses if we elect the
guy who barely leaves his
seriously congress is fighting over a
two trillion dollar stimulus bill but
there could be no greater form of
stimulus than letting
everyone go back to work safely
unfortunately democratic leaders just
won't let us do it
biden reminds us at every turn he sees
the election as a choice between park
avenue and main street
in his framing the president somehow
prioritizes the park avenue crowd
despite the fact that over 90 percent of
actual park avenue residents
donated to democratic campaigns in the
past year but my thing is
if you're going to claim to be the party
on main street it would help to
acknowledge just how many main streets
are getting decimated by the ongoing
economic shutdowns
in democrat-run states in new york alone
it's believed that
50 percent of the bars and restaurants
that close down during the lockdowns
will never
reopen folks do you know how hard it is
to go broke
selling alcohol in a town with two
football teams as bad as the jets and
giants
although to be fair most fans have
probably moved on to stronger stuff at
this point
democrats have also failed to grasp
exactly what the world health
organization reported this week
negative economic realities caused by
shutdowns
have led to a host of dire health
consequences such as a higher rate of
suicide
substance abuse and domestic abuse the
more you examine the lockdown issue the
more you realize democrats have never
been the party of science
so much as the party of bash whatever
trump says because we've got an election
to win
for all their criticisms of trump's
pandemic response biden and the
democrats have yet to explain how they
do
anything differently you know joe likes
to point out that he issued a plan for
combating the virus on march 9th
and yeah that's true but the plan came
six weeks after the president acted by
banning incoming flight from china
a move dr fauci testified under oath had
saved thousands of lives
a move biden criticized at the time as
xenophobic as for the specifics
joe's plan called for quote a decisive
public health response
that involves widely available testing
developing a vaccine
and the distribution of critical medical
supplies
if it sounds familiar it's because these
are all things the president has already
done folks we lead the world in testing
we thankfully suffer no shortage of
supplies
and as you read this we have six private
companies in the home stretch of
developing a vaccine
so for my money i say congress should
stop fighting over a stimulus bill like
they're the real housewives of new
jersey
and let people get back to work because
the truth is americans don't want more
government handouts
they want the dignity of a job which
they can't get if biden and the
democrats continue to push
lockdowns for political purposes joe
biden likes to claim he's the candidate
of the working class
because he's traveled over 2 million
miles by train during his career
but under his pro-lockdown policies it's
the working class
that's getting railroaded open it all up
now
and be sure to listen to me jimmy fella
host fox across america weekdays from
noon to 3 on foxnewsradio.com
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news go to
foxnews.com
from the fox news podcasts network stay
on top of the latest news and
information from fox news
listen and download the fox news hourly
update on your time
the trending stories you need anytime
you want it listen and download now by
going to foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes